STEAD YOU CAON MEMES.
MET THINGS BES
R A COLD DEMTS DEFY L GRAVITD H
D RULEE A SLEWND APPROVARATINGS
OF VICTORIES.
E POLLS HAVEOTCAUGHT UP WI WINS.
BUT WHILE RTBLICANS STIL
RETH A SENATE'S TOP
BULLISH ON THE CHANCES>> I THINI
THEY'RE IDE.IDATE QUALITY HAS AO
OUTCOM
SAYS DEMOCRATS WOULD NEED TOINOD
STATES.
REPUBLICOU JUS
WIN TWO TO W BACK CONTROL.DO
HA SSENATEME TO DISCUSS ISR.Y,
R POCSDICRYSTAL BALL.
GREAT U OPN PUICS H McCONN
PULLING DOWN THE CURTAIN T  A JI
QUO MUYET TO MANY GS
NOER LOOK AT TT SERA
HL,E GHT. H
THE GROUPS THAT DO WHAT MY
CRYSTAL BALL GROUP DOEGG
WOULPROBABLY ENDITH THE MAJORIT
BEHAATEFORE THEYOM
SODIDATES WHO
WAY ARE PERIENCED.EY'VE NEVER R
BUT ITELO HAVE B THEHER BEFORE U
R SENATE.
>>NG MMIND, CHRIE
THS STORY HEODD
TE EXTREME
A
EXM TO WIN, HE EREEYATROM TH
VICTORY.
McCONNELL SAID REMINDE OF
SOMETHINTHAT SOMEONE I
SENATENCE ITCHcC
TE PICTHREPUBLICANEY WOULD WIN A
TION K
BU QUESTION L  HAS ONE ITIOWIWHA
THE REPUBLICAN MINORITY OR
JO
WELL, DOLD
MON
THE RESULTS.
E NUR THE PRESIDL
AND LOOK AT HISTORY,
HAVE TO BEGN
DEMOCRATS TO RETAKE
BYHAT,
HOW MUCHWE THEREFORE I ACRE BOA.
U EA T SE. RWH
HATHE
'T
L THHA T
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS ACTUALLY
A WORD
UENTLY.
YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT W  FEWNTE
VE
VICTORIES.
HE GOT OUT OF 30
HE'SLOW 40s.
T IT NOWHERE NEAR WHER
E TO HELPARTY STAY IN OF.
YOU GOT A  BETWEEN
APPROVAL A HOWMA
THE DEMOCRATIC CANDIS
BUT MY Q MISLL THOSEESE BY
THERE WON'T BE A
WIN.EM FO
IFT  UE  COULDLY BE IGD THEIR T
FAT OKOW
UNPRECEDENTED FORT TIME IERICAN
FORMER PRESIDENT
LINES DAY  INCUMBE JOE N THE NE,
THIRDRY
D HURTIN
IF THEY COUL T ON A
TOUR ID PROBABLY
HELP.
>> FINAL QUEYOU IDENTIFIEDR SEN
BATTLEGROUNDTES.AVE DR. LARRY T
TOTHE ANSWER TO AS B
K E STATE -- EL IT'TRY CLITS DER
NORMALAT'S BECAUSEE HI.RCENTAGET
THE R RE KATHERINE CORTEZ O.
BUT THREPUBLICANS HAVENI
AWAY HPANIEV OF THEOUTHEVTOO, AI
IN THE SENATE RACETH AS A TOTAL
TOSSUP.
NOT THAT THE OTHERAR AT LEAST
T O